we're excited to see this many people
yeah you're going to see that many
people wow i mean that do you get used
to that well it kind of it happened so
gradually it's like i never like became
a singer-songwriter and all of my peers
all of the people that i looked up to
played shepherd's bachempa so i was
always like i want to play shepard's
bush empire and then when you've done
that the next one is like hammersmith so
then you go to hammersmith and then the
next one's wembley state uh arena and
then it's the o2 and then after the o2
it's it's that so it just sort of
gradually happened then suddenly you
find yourself in that situation
and
it's quite a leap and quiet i remember
walking out on stage my first one in
2015 and just being like
i don't know if i'm ready for this but
you just get used to it let me tell you
what wembley's like
[Applause]
yeah wembley i think went there's
there's a new wembley now but yeah that
one was ripped down at some point it was
an incredible moment in that film no
this is not about no yes
all right really really good
man back to you well actually back to
back to ed that idea of a big crowd
we found this picture of you this is
genuinely an early gig for you
i mean that is
that's a big
there's only one chair and it's not sold
out
he's continuing he's doing the gig yeah
yeah
that was that was how it was for like
quite quite a few years i would
basically play anywhere that would let
me and i remember being so surprised the
first day i got like 20 pounds for
playing a show i'd be like you get paid
for this and then yeah and then it just
started kept going on for then i think i
was about 15 here so that's here yeah
that's 2006 i think and i think it's in
debenham in suffolk if anyone's from
suffolk no one all right
look at the legs there are more people
on the other side
[Music]
you